on the line in Detroit Michigan Chris
and Jen on our weather's hey guys how
are ya good are you there I am better
than I deserve so I see on my screen
that you are debt-free we are way to go
very cool how much have you paid off
seventy-seven thousand one hundred and
thirty six dollars and ninety four cents
love it and how long did that take 20
months and a half twenty and a half
months yeah okay all right very cool and
your range of income during that time
our base was at the beginning 63,000 and
now at 71 but we made an average of a
hundred and ten over that time Wow okay
what do you guys do for a living I work
in quality control at eight a major tape
manufacturer okay I'm at reception is
that algae group okay very cool so
what'd you do to get your income up here
in that time because you bumped it about
another thirty grand is what you're
saying yes I worked a lot overtime just
straight up ot huh straight up over here
got it what kind of debt was the seventy
seven thousand oh man it was a lease pay
off medical bills IRS taxes parent loans
credit cards cars and student loans
dadgum you guys were normal we were very
honorable you had everything every debt
in the world
you didn't miss one that's awesome Wow
so how long have you two been married
today is their two-year anniversary oh
so it sounds like getting married was
the catalyst to start cleaning up this
mess yeah yep it absolutely was so how
did that conversation go down tell me
how this started well a few years ago
right before we got married I was
cashing out a couple CDs my parents had
taken out where I was born
and I called my mom from the parking lot
to say how little interest we got from
it and she told me that her and my dad
were really worried about retirement
which terrified me because I knew they
made way more than I did and at the time
I was looking for a house that I
couldn't afford I was about to get
married and yeah we were terrified so I
went home to my apartment and I started
looking up how to pay off debt quickly
and I tripped up on a debt free scream
so I just watched hours and hours and
hours of them and then started your
program
Wow so YouTube channel debt free screams
all posted and there you were absolutely
Wow
they're addicting they really are it's
that's it and now here you are you are
one exactly yeah Wow
so uh Giannini genetic Jenna and I'm
sorry he comes to you and and says okay
I've been addicted to YouTube now to
these people screaming about getting out
of debt what did you say it was kind of
hard at first cause like you know like I
never had a budget I lived with my
sister and my parents we had a house me
and my sister and you know I had a
mortgage it was in my name and I was
like there is no way I can do this I'm
about to get married so my sister
refinance the house and then I got
married and here we go this is your
allottee and now we have our own
mortgage and we have to start doing it
so he kind of like convinced me and we
have to take control of our finances
because it was just ridiculous all these
loans and that we had so I kind of like
started slow was kind of hard for me but
then I had to stick to our budget and
agree with him and see it's the bread
sheet every day yeah so you guys did a
spreadsheet sat down together and
started giving every dollar a name and
getting in attack mode yeah very cool so
when people find out you paid off
seventy seven thousand dollars and 21
months and they say how did you do that
what do you tell them the key to getting
out of debt is or the keys to getting
out of dealer communications you have to
have a budget you have to say no for
purchases like leasing cars and going
out to eat going on vacations all that
stuff like it's just unnecessary things
that you don't really need you just want
them that's why you buy them we just
said no - and that
and also living on less than you make so
cool what about you Chris that's exactly
the way we did it now that's it
there's no harder than that and I easier
than that and yet it is really hard it's
easy to understand what to do but doing
it is a complete pain isn't it people
make fun of y'all oh yeah everybody
thought we were insane and that it's
impossible you uh you can't pay off debt
you're gonna always have a car payment
you're always gonna owe it's impossible
to live without credit cards too it's
amazing how many people really believe
that oh yeah and they think they're
helping you out by telling you oh you're
not going to be able to do this you know
even after we paid everything off they
said you you still need an emergency
credit card what are you gonna do in the
case of an emergency we have to have
money saved it's called an emergency
fund what an idea
wow you guys are fun well it's good to
have you and I'm so proud of you
congratulations we're going to send you
a signed copy of Chris Hogan's
number-one best-selling book retire
inspired because that's your next step
the next chapter in your book is get
wealthy and beyond being incredibly
outrageously generous and because you're
on your way I mean you got rid of
seventy seven thousand dollars for the
debt and now the next thing is get
seventy seven thousand and then get
seven hundred seventy thousand and then
get seven point seven million and and
you know just keep adding some zeroes on
this you can do it and you got a great
start early in your life and early in
your marriage learning to work together
and most people live their whole lives
and don't know how to do what you've
already done so very very well done
alright Chris and Jeanine on Detroit
Michigan seventy seven thousand dollars
paid off in 21 months making 63 to
seventy one thousand dollars counted
down let's hear a debt free scream
that's how it's done right there I love
it
way to go you too way to go way to go
way to go love it
hey guys Rachael Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you